peter baelish known as littlefinger is
one of the most intriguing characters in
game of thrones
he's quietly powerful a clever
manipulator sharp tongued and more than
slightly creepy
littlefinger has said that he tries to
keep his foes confused by his actions
and watching game of thrones you may be
pretty confused yourself
peter has betrayed ned snogged sansa
killed lysa and been competing with
varys in a dramatic stare competition
for four seasons now
what's he trying to achieve who is this
guy
unlike most of the major players of the
game of thrones littlefinger comes from
a small and unimportant noble family
which holds a piece of land here at the
fingers
one of the little ones because of his
father's friendship with hosta tully
peter was lucky enough to be raised a
river run growing up with edmure
lysa and catelyn lysa loved littlefinger
but littlefinger only had eyes for cat
when catelyn was to be married to
brandon stark young peter went so far as
to challenge brandon to a spectacularly
unsuccessful jewel which left him
scarred in more ways than one
in any case brandon got himself killed
by the mad king catelyn ended up with
his brother ned
and littlefinger never won the love of
his dear cat
these events shaped peter as a man you
know what i learnt losing that duel
i learned that i'll never win not that
way
that's their game bear rules
i'm not going to fight them i'm going to
[ __ ] them he learned that to get what he
wants he has to be indirect and
strategic
using tools more subtle than the sword
so it was his political and financial
brilliance and his friends in high
places that drove his rapid rise up the
ranks to the position of master of coin
basically the treasurer for king robert
who managed to spend the throne into
debt despite the huge amount of money
peter was bringing in
peter used his power carefully buying up
property and businesses like brothels
establishing a network of spies and
placing men loyal to him in useful
places
and then season one begins with the
death of the hand of the king
john aaron we find out in season four
that the killer of john aaron was his
wife
lysa littlefinger got lysa his childhood
friend and the woman who's still devoted
to him to poison
jon and then tell her sister catelyn
that the lannisters did it
when catelyn comes to king's landing to
tell ned about the attempted killing of
bran which was possibly ordered by
joffrey but we don't know
littlefinger lies and tells carlin that
the dagger used was tyrion's
leading cat to capture and wrongly
accuse the dwarf
meanwhile peter helps ned uncover jaime
and cersei's incestuous secret but when
eddard confronts the lannisters peter
betrays him and soon
ned's dead all three of these moves were
deliberate attempts by littlefinger to
create conflict between the lannisters
and the starks
and it works peter baelish indirectly
without implicating himself
started the war of the five kings but
why peter says that
chaos is a ladder littlefinger is using
the chaos of war to gain
power for example in season two
littlefinger negotiates an alliance with
the tyrells
this alliance saves the lannisters in
the battle of blackwater so littlefinger
is rewarded with the castle of harrenhal
and rule of the riverlands with this
highest status and again because of the
war littlefinger is sent to marry lysa
in order to secure the military support
of the vale
just about the only region untouched by
the war so he goes and marries the woman
who loves him
and then he kills her with lysa gone and
jon arryn already dead
robert aaron is the only thing standing
between littlefinger and control of the
veil
wouldn't it be terrible if sick frail
sweet robin somehow had an accident
on his way out of king's landing peter
does two things he helps kill king
joffrey
and he takes sansa stark he helped kill
joffrey presumably to create more of the
chaos that he's been doing so well out
of but possibly also to gain favour with
the tyrells now one of the most powerful
houses
but why did he take sansa it's obvious
that he's attracted to her and whether
you want to call that love or some kind
of creepy ass pedo [ __ ] it seems to be
related to littlefinger's love of cat
he's projecting his love of the dead
mother onto the
daughter yeah it's really more of this
isn't it so that's one reason pena takes
answer
but there's another as the last known
living stark sansa is the key to the
north
whoever marries her becomes the lord of
winterfell and has some claim on the
north
of course sansa is already married so
her current husband tyrion would have to
die for her to marry again
but how could the brother of the queen
possibly die ah
littlefinger by the way was the one to
arrange this little entertainment which
succeeded in creating public conflict
between tyrion and joffrey just before
the king died helping to frame tyrion
for the murder and be sentenced to death
freeing sansa up for marriage
or it would have if tyrion didn't escape
anyway so at the start of season 1 peter
baelish was master of coin at king's
landing with this little nowhere as his
official seat
now he's sitting in the airy probably
the safest place in westeros with
control of the veil
of the riverlands potentially of the
north and with the embodiment of the
dead woman he loves in an obsessive
gatsby-esque kind of a way
without lifting a sword he has won the
two things he desires
power and catelyn of course both of
those things come with fairly large
asterisks
he has catelyn only in the form of her
daughter and his control of these
regions is
doubtful i mean he has no army no sworn
lords backing him no love from the small
folk and a ruin for a castle
but he does have the crown backing his
claim at least on the riverlands so
that's gotta count for something
in any case he's a long way from where
he was before and he did it by creating
and exploiting the chaos of the war of
the five kings
the question now is what next it's hard
to say
we've never had a little finger point of
view chapter and we only really see his
actions indirectly
maybe he'll settle down or maybe on a
ladder
the only way to go is up
thanks for watching this video if
there's interest similar videos on other
characters could follow
who do you want to see explained you can
support this channel by subscribing
and sharing and following on facebook
and twitter